greetings from podcast Ville the church
what's happened now is brought to you by
blue apron blue apron is deleting milk
at delivery service in the US and while
many other people know what we do many
don't know about the types of meals you
eat when you cook with blue apron blue
apron is the number one fresh ingredient
recipe delivery service and the country
and right now
blue apron is treating the church family
listeners to that first three meals a
$30 value with your first order if you
visit blue apron comm slash Joey so
check out this week's menu and get your
$30 off with free shipping at blue apron
comm slash Joey blue apron it's a better
way to cook number two listen NFL
playoffs this weekend you still want to
make some Guinness you want to start the
year off with some [ __ ] money in your
pocket all right they're finally here
and I want to tell you guys about my
book e dot AG the number one rated
online sports book period with your
fantasy football season over the only
way to make real [ __ ] money off your
sports knowledge is to win cash by
betting at my bookie all right so right
now if you join my bookie they'll match
your deposit with up to a 50% bonus did
you hear that 50% bonus so just use
promo code Church when making your
account visit my bookie AG today and bet
on the Internet's favorite sports book
where you play you win and you get paid
number three you want to start the year
off with a clean [ __ ] you got to go
with the number one [ __ ] portable
bidet in the country hello
Toshi comes in a variety of colors and
let me tell you something I don't give a
[ __ ] if Christmas is over it always
makes that pest the best present you
will look at some money you go I wonder
what there has those smells like that
ends today by a man hello douchey and
they started $69 with a 90 day money
back guarantee go - hello - she calm and
pressed in church and get 10% off your
first order kick that [ __ ] melee
there you go the Church of what's
happened now my brothers are in the
house
Felipe Esparza with his vegan glasses
and my man [ __ ] in the christ-killers
[ __ ] was a fool it was so happy new year
map in New York regions also announced
he's over there man
he said that thinking about the
Riverside floods of 66 that's what
happens when you do one of those
mushroom stars and [ __ ] we do
mushroom coated stars here move at the
Church of what's happened now your
little tingle in your spine
happy new year happy new year right to
see but to see you actually want to
congratulate you on the HBO special you
created waves it's made of different you
it's a different animal and your eyes
also red as [ __ ] I love it
you know fully pollution say right now
you ever seen old pictures Epling with
Robert Plant all [ __ ] up with his eyes
all red that's what you look like right
now you're like a Mexican Robert [ __ ]
plant yeah Robert Plant ah what's going
on with you Rodrigo you're holding on
for that bond like it's a last bond in
the world the Koreans are about to fire
missile look at you his face looks like
my face in the pain and you're like [ __ ]
that this bond will block the missile
I'll leave it right here it's a
beautiful day to be [ __ ] alive man
what's going on buddy good man I'm
feeling good bro I'm pretty young I
think I ate a one-star that's all you
need and I hit a bunch of momma bunch of
bong rips and I saw Lisa almost choked
to there oh my god that was his first
we're like he's he drowning bronchitis
for like two weeks and the for the
entire two weeks Joy's billing he got a
smoke you got a smoke every other doctor
every commercial you see says don't
smoke when you have a cold
I took one bong hit and everything in my
lung came out that's it
bong hits basically no [ __ ] lungs
it's well known fact I mean I don't know
what that but when you [ __ ] coffee
it's good for your lungs when you call
like that and get all that billy goat
[ __ ] milk out and gastric juices and
whatever the [ __ ] is in there I'm sorry
Lou choked a carful I'm no doctor but
I've had the flu what twenty thousand
[ __ ] times when I've smoked through
all of them and leaving cutting in your
mind that cuts through the flu because
you're telling your [ __ ] mind I don't
give a [ __ ] bring it on [ __ ] but that
backfires from time to time one time in
late 2008 I got a bronc
I this for like eight weeks I couldn't
swim that good new [ __ ] so don't listen
to me anyway what is bronchitis I know
it's like a implement it's like an
infection in the lungs or not yes maybe
it's just liquid in the lungs I don't
know but I've got it I've had it ever
since I smoked hash with Joey you know I
had that thing in my lungs and I was
nice cool so I've always had a lung
problem you know and am i cook I got out
of the hospital they were like you know
what don't be around smoke don't smoke
I got a hospital 1:00 in the afternoon
and by 4:00 I was doing bong hits in by
8:00 I was doing the hit of [ __ ] acid
I was [ __ ] 16 what are you gonna tell
us that's funny
what are you gonna tell [ __ ] 16 year
old people thought I had lung problems
just because of my voice even I was a
kid
cuz I had the same voice I do now when I
was 10 they were damn that homey man he
must smoke a lot of cigarettes
you never had a Michael Jackson voice no
man I was don't worry kid my favorite
make funny ministers relieve pain right
there so your voice always sounded
[ __ ] up he's always telling at this
man Ike something when I talk people say
boy were you from an East Coast nah bro
East LA you know it's funny before we
started the podcast that's what we were
later were just talking about he was in
Boulder last weekend and he asked me if
I would ever consider going back to
Boulder and it's funny because Boulder
but I played Denver it scares the [ __ ]
out of me to have to think to go into a
car and go to bolt like it just cuz God
knows you know when Rogan first went to
boldly called me like two days after he
landed he knows you know all your
stories came into perspective because
this place is like a [ __ ] candy store
for a guy like you yeah and you know
what is disgusting and oblique you can
push doors down the weather lowlife as
it sounds I mean that's why I don't go
back because I'm disgusted with myself
for the [ __ ] I did in Boulder because if
I did that [ __ ] New Yorker wouldn't
matter if I did that [ __ ] in Jersey or
in any way it wouldn't matter that
[ __ ] dirty communities whatever the
[ __ ] we are you know but the [ __ ] I
didn't Boulder bro didn't deserve that
that's just they didn't deserve that at
all you know and it's like I told you
the first time I went to Boulder I
didn't like it it was too many hippies
from but think about that just I'd said
that to you
just to let you know how much it changed
like the first time I stepped foot in
Boulder was uh like maybe September of
83 I went down there for a weekend and I
[ __ ] hated it
I [ __ ] hate like I wasn't used to tow
I never know what tofu was I never knew
I was right out of New York City I had
no idea what half that food was and I
had zero appreciation for it like zero I
was too young the first time I went to
bowl then I went back to Boulder two
years later and I went on the you
district I went into that to the hill
yeah and naturally I was like wow I'm
staying in this [ __ ] it was
clean there was hippies but not too many
hippies you know what I called it peace
they were like homeless young kids and
they buy that that age I was robbing for
a living I wasn't [ __ ] asking for no
[ __ ] handouts so that's why I got so
frustrated because I'm like look at
these young kids act asking for handouts
with a door gonna check well it's
[ __ ] crazy in the beginning Felipe
like my first friend was a guy that
believed in Satan I was a Satan guy his
name is like our the sunjin bad aura
that's who I bought weed from like the
first [ __ ] huh gooey but I met him
on the Boulder walk like that when I
first moved to Boulder I knew nobody
then we're seen it's a boulder ro
Motorama
Boulder oughtta go right over the water
first time I walked into the boulder I
didn't know anybody
I mean nother so I went to my house I
put my clothes in I went to the bodega
whatever [ __ ] the bodega in those
days was uh
alfalfa's which is Whole Foods in in
Boulder I went to how far is groceries
were sixty bucks
I was like what the [ __ ] is this you
know I just bought this is 20 hours back
in New York but that was our fatherís I
didn't know what the [ __ ] this was
everything was uh you know organic meat
[ __ ] that doesn't sound like a bodega
know I didn't know what it was man and
then oh I ain't [ __ ] with kale
I [ __ ] started walking around and I
was like this was a perfect foot place
for me to be at 22 I joined the gym
you're 22 or made you go to Boulder or
anyone
warrants okay police people I owed money
to Boulder Colorado basically Hawaiian
land yes the way the people are yes and
I said that that before we started the
podcast boldly gets his much sunshine
yearly as much as Hawaii like it's a
[ __ ] beautiful place it really is
it's a attracts of weird people and like
I said I got where I was getting weed
that 30 years ago that would have killed
the [ __ ] animals this [ __ ] I was
getting grown up in that high altitude I
was getting some good when I was getting
better weed and Aspen but like I was
telling you man it was just from 85 and
Boulder to 88 tonight no I'm lying to
you the 10 years I created havoc in that
[ __ ] town like have it habit internal
havoc if it was missing I had something
to do it I'm not proud of that I'm not
very proud of that at all but that's who
I was back then [ __ ] crazy but it's
something you know like you just you
just have a knack for it no like because
if you like if you're a gangster like in
New York you know Detroit you go to a
small town at that like watch it like
Joe Rogan say where everybody there is
super super cool
they're not looking for that no it's not
it yourself they're not looking for that
man you could walk in there man and you
test them out you know the gas station
by taking 20 power bars at once so like
I can't even a like imagine a world
without cameras I think there's always
been cameras when I've gone in the
stores so like what kind of security was
there like nothing nothing nothing to my
first born person watching the whole
story the riot I'll never forget going
to the mall but I was telling Felipe
that I gotta I got him a law settlement
for my shoulder and I put money away and
I made a promise to start a new life
how'd you better be a soldier I messed
it up lifting but the night before I did
the scam I fell against the floor and I
was with side Lawrence the [ __ ] Jew
that used to do the fake could actually
[ __ ] your shoulder up for it it would be
you have to go to the hospital with
something you just gonna walk at the
hospital go my shoulder hurts so we went
up against the wall and scraped it a
little bit I banged it a lot I banged it
they're not gonna have the [ __ ] joy
you know give said leave the weapon and
I [ __ ] won in there and then they had
a cahoots with the attorney and the
attorney [ __ ] hooks you up with the
doctors and the doctors are under this
something Armenians in Glendale oh my
god then they all go in on the small
[ __ ] 10% and everybody's a little
[ __ ] and everybody I talk to you you're
like I'm the x-ray guy
you're the [ __ ] it's like a scam it
would blew my mind and I took them and I
forgot about it because in the process I
robbed the chiropractor so when the
process of [ __ ] it was the night that
boom boom Mancini killed Newcombe Kim in
the center in the cell that was the
night the same thing I remember being at
the chiropractor's office and watching
this fight and nobody was even on the
phones
you know nobody the nurses that was
supposed to be answering the phone they
were watching the fight on the Saturday
afternoon and there was a [ __ ]
envelope and I took in three days later
they arrested me so I thought the case
had gone sour
I thought the case with my shoulder had
gone sour I got a call one day that the
parody had my check in this [ __ ] desk
and I went down and I picked up to check
on Friday and I was on a plane on Sunday
guys that's how quick and I was on the
plane I was headed to Colorado Springs
but I ended up in [ __ ] Boulder
because some black dude talked me into
going to bald man you don't want to go
to Colorado Springs man that's an armed
to town you want to go to bowl that's
what a ball would hold it so I went to
Boulder and Busters over there
no that's not my bag so it wasn't my bag
when you were there with any other any
other people doing the same thing you
were doing you're the only one to my
knowledge I hang by myself
and then I met then the blessing of my
life this guy the like I said this guy
no way before the wolf way before the
wolf I met this guy named Fred Edie Edie
Edie I met him through rah rah was the
devil guy that sold weed and he'd have a
navitat young girls
hanging out with him and [ __ ] and
[ __ ] uh you know he one day he
introduced me the head and head me and
rock got weed from the same hippie lady
up on the hill
she was the you Jana she was like fifty
and her boyfriend was like twenty he was
a rich little nerd his father invented
like glue and they were both trucks for
the kids and they would hate society
like [ __ ] this and [ __ ] that but your
trust fund this well you got to hate him
as I'm all they did all day was smoke
dope and sit there they didn't have a
job they didn't do nothing in there
about five she would send them to the
store they got like a bottle and they
would get drunk and that's all they did
but I met this dude named Edie and I
hung out with Ed for a few weeks until I
knew what ed was ed told me he was in
the army so about two weeks go by and me
and had gone on the hill and there's
this place called Stella's and they used
to have a this was way before Boston
Market guys they used to have the spit
chicken Chasseur chicken rotisserie
chicken and everybody went there for
chicken when you had to wait on line
there for the chicken I would go in the
afternoons and me and head go there one
day bro when we get there as a bunch of
cops outside and they have a barricade
and there's a dude on top of the Fox
Theater and he's saying that he's gonna
jump I'll never forget this bro and it's
like job [ __ ] and that's the dad
I fell in love him but cops kept saying
bro please you're just gonna make the
situation worse he was a lot of time for
this he's yelling at the guy job jham
jham and then I became friends with that
that was it and then I got into trouble
the cops are looking around at the San
Francisco and then I came back two years
later and that's when I started my
destruction but I read up with it and I
still didn't know what I did and got
checks he said he used to go to the VA
then he heard noises I knew he went to
Vietnam but I always thought he was a
medic and I always stayed friends with
Edie Edie Edie
head and one day I was up by Chautauqua
Park where you were performing by the
bull Dorado up there yeah and I saw Edie
walking and I go ahead what are you
doing he goes this is where I live
because you want to come over and roll
the joint man when I went in his house
guys it was an apartment maybe the size
of this and a basement up by Chautauqua
and it was just [ __ ] medals pictures
of him with six guys with 20 bodies dad
with him with like you know how they put
the flag on the mountain yeah with like
a flag and a bunch of Chinese bodies
Vietnamese Bob dog this guy was [ __ ]
crazy and I gotta you were medically
just know he told me he was something
else a lope or a LARP or one of those
things and they go in after the Green
Beret and make sure everything's dead
like every rat every Mouse they burned
the village down they're the ones that
used to throw the cards those dudes were
told the cards in the dead bodies and
dog that's what I felt I found the
[ __ ] Allied but I had like three guys
like that around me that lived in the
hills of Colorado there that you didn't
know they were just put into they were
just walking around these guys were
killers bro bold is a weird place big
drugs you hit the nail on the head there
you got a killer blow that you get rid
of it in two hours two eyes Lord say
those college kids are filthy [ __ ]
rich and they get money to [ __ ] spend
on drugs bro steroids go fast there it
was amazing it was an education for me
and it would it taught me a different
level of survival like what I was doing
in New York didn't work in Colorado I
had to switch it up to make it work and
I'm ashamed of that till today I'm very
ashamed that what are you gonna do have
you heard how it's changed man oh I know
I talk to people from Boulder once a
week I did I remember um I did a show
and I'm Aspen with David Brenner they
were written or picked are like some
comedian that he thought were funny so
he picked me this Asian comedian Kevin
Shea and Miguel what's his name
Miguel from we got Washington from
Houston I've never been to Aspen you
know and I was like surprised we were a
legend
but after the show bro I went to this
bar and I said and I started drinking
I'm gonna messed up I started drinking
and right away bro like I just took a
turn to the right and you know like I'm
like you know I was drunk but I get when
I get drunk I feel like I'm gonna find
coke fast like with magical powers so I
said I told myself when I change to the
right this guy right here that I have
coke and I turned around there was a
Mexican dude like uh some kook who just
came out of work and after I talked to
him in Spanish and that fool had a whole
bag bro coke and let's look at that foot
to my apartment right to my hotel room
and um for a long time we were partying
bro
right we were [ __ ] partying then and
I had a nice room brought in a real nice
room like it was like a nice room it was
a cabin basically like I could walk down
and open the refrigerator and take stuff
out if I wanted well I can't do that but
I did I went downstairs and I took I was
taking wine bottles out and anyways I'll
make long story short this guy man he
thought that Kevin Shea and his
girlfriend were gonna come back and
party he doesn't gonna be a chick there
bro so then I told him there ain't no
chick right so then this food thought
that I don't know man but you were
looking at me bro like with maybe maybe
you could be the cheeky Oh No
but it got weird bro and then I stand
for is about that I don't want but then
again bro I didn't want that for the
leave Brooklyn I had no more coke and I
was leaving the next day in the morning
I was just gonna ask is that weird to
temp party will it was just a guy hell
no bro you know but sometimes you gotta
dance with the devil bro so you know
what I did bro I got I took $100 and I
cut it in half and I gave it a him be
stay another hour bro give you the other
half
but it was good coke and Aspen my way
that was always Pat buck was a bro that
was a very crazy time - man that was I
walked him to Aspen a kid Felipe I
walked him to Aspen a 19 year old kid
how the world yep if you had a bunch of
warrants or you have you know friends Oh
at that time I just didn't wanna live in
jail like I knew just new lifestyle yeah
I just wanted to do something different
than that and at that time I had friends
in Aspen they weren't like people good
friends but they were quite in system
North Bergen and there were one strong
family there was one family that that
was well known it was two of those boys
and it was weird cuz I didn't get along
one of the other brothers but I got
along with two of the brothers one of
the brothers that was my brother now is
dead
and the other guy was in San Diego you
don't talk to me but I went out there
with them and a guy named my name Duffy
and there was four dude who lived in the
house and then other guy was a karate
expert from California he was the
garbage man and he was really a garbage
man in real life and half the guys that
came out from Jersey were all garbage
men when I got there I couldn't be a
garbage man because karate man had come
back to California for some so I lived
in his room it was just a fucked-up
summer that summer
you saw the cars there what no I uh the
first couple of months I did
construction outside like asphalt and
like just regular Rodrigo did have a
video with you man or your voice
he was polar that's where I began yeah
none of it's wrong where it all began no
no but I wasn't I was in Aspen that I
was at Aspen that think it's dig it dig
a trench you see the trick joke I would
quit a job every Friday no one on my you
know I used to go through that like how
about my dad hooked me up to a cool job
but cool job for him about working 12
hours a day so there are three counting
the hours that's a man in a week he's
gonna it's gonna feel like I work two
weeks so pay day care bro
disappeared and I took a lot of
wonderful photos factory bro
I was working joy from manly you don't
understand when you get a check
in high school oh no the world come down
on you what when you did a girl paraded
in high school the world cooked on you
play everybody wants to make changes so
my dad got me a job and on Anderson
Street right there in downtown LA grew
up with all the proto factory there at
and I was loading and unloading produce
inside trucks from eleven o'clock at
night
no from midnight to 11:30 11:30 in the
morning and nothing but Bisons bro like
makin D remember fro nothing or me was
it was a little bit above the minimum
wage living wage was 335 I was getting
forced a birdie how [ __ ] scary is that
you're right we never talked about that
knocking somebody up in [ __ ] ice high
school bro
I don't wanna knock anybody a high well
how old is this child now this foo is
like how state his 20s bro like 20 he's
marching riddled aged 27 28 he talkin
but we have Romney it's a I stand I
stand on presents every Christmas he
don't call back
no he don't call back we met each other
like and right after Last Comic Standing
okay so you knock her up in high school
where'd she go did you move in with her
and trying to make it work no we moved
in to we are we moved in together and we
were living together in the housing
projects in high school no she wasn't
I was like come we're outta high
schoolers - in high school or high
school now we got pregnant one with both
in high school but she had a baby while
she was in high school and I was like I
was gonna repeat 12th grade but I don't
want to go back to school you quit I
quit like I didn't quit yeah [ __ ] that
man I don't wanna go back what graduate
at 20 [ __ ] that I'm a [ __ ] 19 already
in high school
it's bad enough yeah so man I remember
um like she still has to finish high
school right her mom said you know she's
pregnant and um she's underage
she's 17 and she went to a school
li you know with nothing but loser
chicks go to like like if you're a chick
who got who got prey I'm sorry I wanna
say loser but most of these girls were
pregnant like thirteen year old
twelve year olds 14 year old girl
pregnant
this was like a pregnant high school
girl that's terrible and every time I
went through the picker and then like I
will go pick her up all the time and
stolen cars or our cars didn't belong to
me how are you how do you get those well
in my neighborhood like a crapper sin'
one bike rack will come you know it was
no money and yet no money right so the
car yeah so we'll give him like 220 or
$40 worth of crack to borrow his car for
like four hours and then we will go to
the beach and some of my friend would do
those use the same car do a commit a
crime you know how long did you stay
with this girl my brother oh man I stood
with her from while from the moment she
got praying to my Wow two years because
we had the first kid and I was like in
1999 87 88 89
I remember 90 and now right away we had
another one right away like a year and a
half later we had another kid a girl and
earthquake came through bro and
shattered the project's actually I mean
the project looked the same but it was
like though it was like a big old
earthquake and when everybody were
living it basically in the streets in
the pot house and the housing projects
like because everybody was just scared
to sleep instead of projects dude if you
would if you look you woulda came to my
neighborhood window when I don't know I
don't know for the Northridge earthquake
although with your narrow earthquake but
it was like a big earthquake our house
our neighborhood looked like like calm
like a third-world country bro like City
of God it was just blankets and tents
all over the neighborhood because nobody
wanted to go inside and get crushed by a
[ __ ] building
so that's terrifying and especially to
kids so uh her mom dies and then she I
found out that she's cheated on me for a
year and a half with a different guy
like cheating on me you know like really
[ __ ] cheating on me that's nice I
know man and so I'm crushed bro you know
you know and then what do you do man you
know you beat her ass now
you know you take a body bro at the same
time bro that this is happening you know
um I see one of my friends gets shot and
killed at the same time and I have to go
be a [ __ ] um I threw them out there no
man I was trying to get away from all
that stuff you know but but they all of
us got picked up and we have to go
testify in a murder Jesus and um and I
remember I didn't wanna I didn't want to
go man because you don't want to get
involved right but I remember like I had
to sit there and watch cuz what happened
was we're all in the stainless park bro
and we were all hanging out and it was
and then these guys started chasing us
and I ran the opposite way that's what I
would do and then um at the same time
that we were running from these guys
were running from the guys another her
friend was coming at us didn't know what
was going on so we passed them and that
food takes off bro
so that food is killed right there your
friend yeah how old you say 14 how you
were 14 - no I was like 19
oh jeez also 18 okay right yeah you know
I was a loser bro what the [ __ ] I was
doing hanging out with 14 year olds bro
so you know but he was your fella
and now we were hanging out the park
these kids were ditching school how
would you do school hey get out bro and
we have to go to court man but this is
the craziest [ __ ] ever bro like I'm
doing a showing on terror in prom and
this woman comes up to me like laughing
drunk as hell having a good time she
grabbed my hand like this he was my
brother
he's it you look familiar my brother
he's in prison right okay and then this
this asian chick gives me her card bro
so oh sure the guy that I'm supposedly
who killed my friend he's trying to come
out of prison now [ __ ] all right
I'm not [ __ ] now for all I didn't know
all this blah blah it all just came to
me right now when we're talking about
this right I'm like okay I won't go was
the Ontario incident when did all that
was like now five years so the guy that
killed your friend in like 20 years he's
up to 25 the [ __ ] mistakes we
could've made Felipe this couldn't ended
up like this you know I know bad weed
that you gotta give thanks to somebody I
know I think God about that because when
I think about it sometimes you know we
were all together and then I decided you
know for some you know you know people
say that I'm you know somebody looking
out for me but my mom will probably
praying bro you know at the same time or
my grandmother
Lucia salto with her big old [ __ ]
medallion you know and her big tubes
yeah go she do have those [ __ ] big
earrings I said Joey you know I said um
well you know I said you know what
hey man I'm gonna cross the bridge and
we're gonna see if they if I see those
guys coming over here I'll let you guys
know and the thing is [ __ ] woman and
debt this bond
oh my god I know they're making love to
it impression oh my god poor poor poor
[ __ ] Danielle Oh bro
oh my god you know Felipe crazy though
man I decided to go over the bridge so
when I cross the Hollenbeck Park bridge
to go to the other side I soon as I turn
around that's when everybody was running
and getting shot up geez and I remember
my friend Ruben I know I never forget
her man I feel picked that for bro and
carried on crazy man
was it like was that like a moment that
like maybe think about changing some
things are no no it's so rough now bro
you feel invincible after that it I mean
I live now but it's [ __ ] up because
I'm the guy who got killed and his
brother was there twins dog they're
twins so I thought we were all getting
[ __ ] up you know you know you know
being sad because he passed away I
remember kept looking at him looking
himself in a mirror and getting sad
especially for twins that's supposed to
be like a special yeah well let's find
out man
and I'm and it's funny because I saw
Sarah subin's Sean I think it's Netflix
yeah yeah she has father Greg Boyle
that's why you could and when I saw and
one of the books talks about that murder
but um I'm just thankful man that I'm
for the great boy and I'm I still a show
and I thankful you call me every week
and check up see what's up Conseco do
you want to explain what that is because
like I I'd seen the salsa but I had no
idea who father Greg Boyle was like
don't explain who he is
oh for the great Boyle man he's a Jesuit
priest a Catholic from my church the
Lauren mission and he started a program
called homeboy industry and they help
ex-cons
and people who are you know in gangs
find decent jobs and they help him
skills and the a-bomb tattoo removal and
they don't just take Mexican gangsters
to man there's a lot of neo-nazi
lowriders brought with the Nazi tattoos
like swastika on her neck and they
getting removed there for free nice and
I've been donating for to them saying
that one that's coming standing you were
part of the were you part of the group
yeah what happened with what time man I
was like me I love terminator man
terminator somebody that was a minute or
two oh yeah I know smart [ __ ] so I
mean um I used to drink a lot I to drink
those little while don't you know
you remember the little wine coolers but
they're not wine coolers they had like
iced Long Island iced tea some of them
were pine at the pre main yeah horrible
I saw you drinking those [ __ ]
pre-made cocktails I picked up in the
afternoon they gave us $200 to hang out
for me for an hour
oh my god he used to drink the plug
those things give you heartburn from the
[ __ ] jump like whatever the mixer
isn't there yeah I used to drink those
things when in deep situations like late
night when it didn't matter no more but
to start the day that's a completely
remember I even had the pre-made Bloody
Marys
yes they're the boy thing pre-made book
premium uh slice but I know
[ __ ] who used to drink those
and throw two lemons or lime in them on
a piece of celery and tip top Magoo dog
they even put more bark in it I would be
cooked out right like that but that when
you saw me that moment that time I saw
myself you know what Miley my fruits
give me 2 Peter colada and some ice and
I put it all inside of a coke Cup oh do
you ever think him and I am Felipe you
and I both know that we hate those type
of people that you know oh no because I
did this and I did that brah was a loser
and it's such a fun thing to tell people
that you were a loser instead of telling
people all these grandioso stupid
stories that you really weren't but it's
amazing like I'm not gonna tell you I
got shot at all the time I'm I'm some
fortunes and that's [ __ ]
but there's a part of me that's really
fortunate just even doing the drugs and
the places you had a go to to get drugs
and the people you bought like used to
bring people home I would never bring
nobody home you want to sell it to me
and not either or I got cash the last
person I wanted to bring to my house was
a [ __ ] man you know I'm saying and
some women that just [ __ ] you gotta
watch them too cuz they'll rob you
quicker than a [ __ ] dude you know
it's just such a different lifestyle
like this year I woke up I went to bed
at 10 o'clock on New Year's and next one
I woke up Felipe for Ana how
sat at that desk watching my wife and
baby sleep thinking what the [ __ ] I used
to do on New Year's Eve
I used to be right in the heart of it
you know like right in the heart of it
you always in the heart of it you know
how [ __ ] lucky
how [ __ ] lucky Felipe we could have
died doing coke we could have died
smoking crack you know it's gotta be
something you have to give back at one
point you have to go there has to be
somebody who watched over me
I just cannot be this lucky you know I
am like just to stop snorting coke you
know the animal I was Felipe you know
the animal I was and I get so many
emails from people and now that we have
the church page people at you all the
time man they're trying to get clean and
I try to tell you know it's easy it's
easier than what it seems you know like
it really is it's just this little bump
and you don't see yourself ever being
clean ever having a normal life like
people because we feel like you and I
have never felt like we've been normal
we've always been the outside or
something you know you won last Comic
Standing and they have a site you
especially HBO because Netflix didn't
want really you even look at Netflix
what they got and they want you you and
I have always been like the dirty dogs
economy like they always took us last
time so everything I it's like I was
telling me or somebody the other day The
Longest Yard was on and it was one of
those days I was home my wife is home
and I watched it for like three minutes
and my wife said something to me she was
how did you feel while you were shooting
them you know I felt to be honest it I
made my [ __ ] point I made my point I
tried to tell you [ __ ] be they
won't listen to me you wanted to talk
about the other guy Here I am and once I
got I like to leave this on the podcast
the other day I was ok
it's like book the longest shirt then
they started really hating me
well Sony had to kiss the Indians yeah
once you kiss once I booked The Longest
Yard they really started hate me I
didn't hate me enough now they really
started hating me cuz now I spit in
their [ __ ] face so you wouldn't get
me when I have always been those
guys I'd like for you to pull off Last
Comic Standing
that was 22 ass [ __ ] hell we picked
you they had dad they're [ __ ]
favorites and [ __ ] and who they wanted
and who was witty but sometimes it don't
look like that for guys like us
something that streets got your back
sometimes the street has your back
really does they do even does they
remember something you did when you help
somebody cuz I did so many shitty things
oh I started off by saying that 25 years
20 years ago you will get people like
that yeah those are the people that you
were like wonder while you were there
bro there's some guy that's like I will
keep to my short San Jose and I saw you
at the Modesto with Joey cocoa what
about the [ __ ] guy just showed up to
save our Sacramento Luke bland right
Louis bland ball coach how many gigs did
he give us back in the early [ __ ]
2000s that guy when we needed every dime
of that like every [ __ ] dime was
necessarily you had to go home with
every [ __ ] dime because it was the
ash the building get paid
yeah man look in the [ __ ] change your
life people at home there were pair of
cash and then I hit home where y'all
want to go to strip bars funnel to
after-hours there's no man think of
7-eleven they think of home James you
want to take us to a party of robbers I
know the [ __ ] theater Jodie I could
eat my gonna call your [ __ ] homies
and tell them that we're here with cash
in our pockets cuz I remember
[ __ ] on eight hundred in their
pocket they were going down I was
getting 200 at one way or another before
they left his house one way another I
was even gonna [ __ ] rob them or sell
them coke and take to hug you but
somewhere another I was getting 200 in
that cash in my pocket hell yeah bro so
even if it was just the taste something
he gonna get piriform right at Martina
brother she locate where she go she
gonna go get Carbajal ha ha ha we used
to eat Felipe that's those [ __ ]
Mexican gigs those texts and gigs like I
don't even know like somebody just hit
me up and asked me if I wanted to go to
McLaren and I think Alan McAllen I said
they hit me up too late man I already
got the plane ticket it's four hours
from Austin right
I would have gone down there I would
have flown in to Macau first cuz I
haven't been done in a while just to get
two of those tacos we [ __ ] love her
food there Brad the food that man but
hello how long have you been doing
comedy for that obviously 20 years 21 21
yeah 96 my first TV created wherever
2007 about 22 now so when would the
rumors the first time you got on stage
little brother
oh man I love on stage at the natural
fudge and I'm fountain Avenue and I love
the boarding was there
Brian Holtzman was there Jamie Kennedy
and the Mooney twins and scintilla beans
Naveen and um that was like that was
1995 94 late 94 and I didn't know about
going up every week they brought I came
out of rehab and want to be a comedian
but I know how like there were no
computers there was no social media so
on to the log on to the public library
and I asked the librarian and he helped
me out here man I'm trying to find the
copy books on comedy writing so we'll
just hit there bro really need them
books Steve Allen cheaper at teen Perret
you know it's uh [ __ ] yeah yeah people
don't know Brody called a gene Perez I'm
gonna break it down at levels where I
would break it down levels for you in
here Neil ready for tonight's show I had
the workshop and for a Bob Hope
yeah Bob Hope you know what's up come on
Doc you were go on the road with Bob
Hope I read all the gene Perez books
when I started the work element and
never did nothing for me 25 years later
little with shitty writer and I did all
the exercises I could look you in the
eyes and tell you I did every one of
those I believe gene Perret I still do
Jeep has never got to meet you forever I
still do keep well tell you in that book
are okay see you so there was one time I
let the books around Lee can you inter
can you google team for read books I had
to write three of them which ones did
you have I had the one that where I have
one right
yeah I had the one where I'm coming
riding with Jeep around I mean I think
was comedy writing 101 I think I don't
know and um it's just about him touring
with Carson and some other comedians you
know Jack Paar jackpot yeah and now he
set that up so he will bring it down at
this so I had to do 10 25 just about
golf for Steve Allen so what he would do
like who put like ok golf on one section
and then once the X 8 he'll write you
might hope right done all the equipment
had to do with golf and the next thing
she said is all that hard work he'll
write down things that people stayed
during all four or five then over here
he will write um
golf courses he's heard you know or say
he'll write funny things you've heard
golf players say so that's just
personally company like come up with
ideas it whole place a lot of work it's
a lot of organizing organizing so yeah
here's 12 books on Amazon but if one of
the books but he has a young comedy
writers this is the [ __ ] I'm problem
with [ __ ] man see this is how I know if
you did your [ __ ] homework enough
because in the beginning if you fall in
love with something you will read
everything line of everything and I was
turned down
Judy Carter was first then it was Jean
Perez that really bought into jean paree
even though I suck guys I'm not gonna
lie to you though another book to it the
yellow book it was called hunter right
funny be funny and make fun I never read
that how to be funny and this one will
break down know how to write funny be
funny and make money out of being funny
and that book will teach you how to like
you gotta go to J Perez first of all
first to get you know the other book and
then um and then that book will tell you
like all the different styles like
Steven right he's dumb one-liner
whatever you know and then I'm writing
Dangerfield this side you know Bob can't
go away and then there was like little
jokes about all these comedians in the
book Jay Leno's jokes Marga show bro you
know a lot of older fools and Robert
Schimmel like a would he would give you
a joke of this and then write like
something about yeah but you're the
father
yeah I remember that buddy handsome here
like pitch in here like he will break
down a choke over like geometry with a
little line okay I'm set up the Paul in
the punch line
yeah pretty [ __ ] interesting [ __ ] I
read that stuff I used to get coked up
and do the exercises at night like till
5:00 in the morning like I would work
five hours on that on Tuesday nights
when I was at the comedy maybe three
years my friend was a baker his name was
Joe Koch he ended up mine that joined
Mississippi in Starkville and he would
bake all night and I would sit with him
and do gene Perret 101 books all [ __ ]
night I would sit down he would give me
all the things to sample I got quite 400
[ __ ] pounds well the boss does he
have he starts off with the comedy
writing self talent workbook has a
hundred practical writing skills to
develop your comedy writing the new
comedy writing step by step it's been
revised yeah yeah yeah yeah comedy
writing self-taught the professional
skill building course and writing
stand-up sketch in situation what you
well you know these books written the
new comedy writing step by step is oh
seven oh seven I think it could be one
of these no they were revised right
because I was getting his [ __ ] in 92 me
too I was reading his [ __ ] I was doing
the workshops in 93 the comedy writing
workbook is 94 yeah
and remember like and then well I I got
into all this and then I will start
renting cassettes you know a library
like Lenny Bruce like actual VHS is and
I was just out reading and [ __ ] all nerd
style man and um well I was somebody I
went to LA Weekly and that's how I found
the natural fudge and but where was the
natural [ __ ] it was a fountain Avenue
now it's a they would have punk rock
music and then I could meet comedian
where the next punk rock band performed
and this guy would name was Johnny
Roberts and he had a local-access show
monday nights where he will put up
the comedy show on local axis but I
don't know what look what axis was so
the first day I go up there man and I
see the Mooney twins and I said man what
do these guys what do these guys Amish
you know and everybody laughed but I'm I
had no jokes but then a guy like me
right Johnny cuz they were like they
were like the crowd like me you like son
you're pretty funny come back next week
we're having a live taping for my cable
show and that's how far okay cable show
bro so I was like funky cuz I don't have
a car back there so I went to with my
homey
Rodney eNOS to the Native American and
from the Pima Papago tribe him and I
used to get drunk a lot Elita call of
young drunks Oh dancing with Wolves
because we should get [ __ ] up bro
let me tell you bro these [ __ ]
they were Native American
Ronald risky beers Alfred first care
down
Nelson bro then we're all Native
American bro about like a year apart and
we should get [ __ ] up anyway so I was
sober bro and came on a rehab so I took
Rodney with me we went through the bus
they were telling you I was too comedy
all I know was 80s comedy bro like Bobby
Collins bro you know I mean right now
people like that you know Tom Rose you
know I know I know I'm you know you got
into comedy this Katie's content was a
lot more TV show a lot of TV shoulder
toward comics like you really got like I
remember Felicia Michael listen
Michael's from TV like I remember
watching being an open-mouth comedy him
too I remember Bobby on HBO
I remember the chicken on HBO when do
you leave me that there's the room now
but I wanted to point something out to
you real quick not to interrupt you Lee
yes know the people that you going on
you see at the fourth wall yeah every
night as minut is the sounds three of
those people are gonna be [ __ ] Lucy
case from there yeah and they don't know
it did you hear the lineup that he told
you who was there the first time he got
on stage she really remembers it
such a [ __ ] honor like I can look at
Felipe go Felipe we've been doing comedy
together oh yes
for 20 years when you came here I was in
my thirties and we did comedy together
that's a certain bond who loves you to
the left and I'm not talking about he I
know it as a comic no I'm talking about
it but I used to do 25 shows of you with
Felipe we knew the insides and outs
we got booked together got booked
together I mean it's been such a
beautiful [ __ ] journey as a comic
because he's like you know he's like the
Ralphie click in my heart he's part of
that Ralphie re-click in my heart like
that that is we've been together not
that he's been a comedian for 20 years
together that's a very weird thing when
you go with somebody and you all this
poor bastard look you dress like one of
the dark owns or what's it what's the
Mexican band that sings about my
choppers Lobos a Lobo look at the more
he needs is the insignia of the wolf on
his jacket that's different oh man
but it's weird how sitting here with you
and what we do when we go to the fourth
wall when I look at those guys on stage
and then I get laughs let me tell you
something three of those 20 kids are
gonna be louis c.k in ten years they
don't know it it's a lot of retaken
that's all I mean Cynthia the vent
alonso bought the movie twins they were
all that Jamie Kennedy Jamie Kelly you
know that 100 ooh [ __ ] Jimmy care
they living in his car I think I just he
wasn't even have enough to ever eat are
you listening to this at home you know
like he was he well he was um he didn't
know where his career was gonna take him
listening to this people he was struck
it was like basically dude like like um
he didn't have enough for a grilled
cheese he was living in his car here to
park it and hide it right there by salt
by the by the [ __ ] I was far go out
there I'll a factory you know just to
let you know at home nobody strolls into
this no man
nobody walks into my hand you [ __ ] I'm
telling you that nobody handed
shitman telling you that's 2018 I've
been doing Tommy next to this guy since
he was a kid since to 97 I want to do
the math and yet this has not been like
somebody just handed you something and
go oh you're gonna get a special on see
so HBO you know I got this kid Philippe
I didn't want to talk about this on the
show but I have to talk about this
because it [ __ ] pisses me the [ __ ]
off
I got a kid that about two years ago he
started hitting me up from my hometown
hey how you doing before about we know
the same people but I looked at him he's
[ __ ] 30 years younger than hell but
after about six months are they going
back and forth it started with the do
you mind if I tape your set and I'm like
this is my first time it got them they
have a camera feeling the same they have
a camera they tape the [ __ ] they tape
a show on axes [ __ ] cable on there if
I want a tape I get it from him I didn't
I just don't want to get in the back
with a stand the place is sold out yeah
you know man I am I just don't want it
but I just wanted them nice if I want to
tape all I got to do is tell him to take
the tape okay that's that number to
[ __ ] about a month later he hits me
up there isn't know what he wants to do
I [ __ ] you know me bro I take an hour
out of my [ __ ] day and write him an
extended plan this is what you need to
do ain't nobody coming did you just see
what I told you guys when I moved to
Boulder and nobody nobody nobody
it's not like somebody says I'll go and
see rah on the mall this is me we were
going to Italian you why I know Felipe's
done this you go to town Phillipe and
you're walking and you have no drugs and
you're jonesing and you basically buying
drugs behind contact yeah you know what
that's like Lisa had had a bit rare no
you don't we it's a different [ __ ]
world when you have to go like like you
come here how many in Studio City what
are we going to dog when language on see
you go to Murray t you got a coffee and
you might see a guy with a tattoo of a
devil or something and you go up to him
and service on my father I just moved
here from Kentucky and I [ __ ] I'm
jonesing for weed this is way before
marijuana it's
when you got it up to something say I'm
looking for you know what if there are
cop you have to [ __ ] and take a chance
you know what a cop looks like you're a
street person a cop always had this
shirt nicely tucked there yeah you know
what a cobbler fine so you just go up to
I'm gonna listen man I didn't look
that's why you don't go up to him and
ask him for heroin knucklehead
you've thrown up slow and you start off
slow with a little reefer and then he'll
sign you he'll go bridled smoke weed I'm
sorry but my brother says if you go down
to the train station over North
Hollywood and I'm just saying these
people you could get read down there so
now you ask people in the North
Hollywood train station is and you walk
over there and you walk and get a hot
dog because you're not an [ __ ] you
know you're not a [ __ ] junkie you'll
do it the right way it's like when I go
to the weed store and I see a kid
parking from the weed so I'm gonna smack
them don't park in front of each store
this is a residential name but they're
gonna know punk down the corner you
can't be that stupid
who the [ __ ] raised you you don't Park
you don't go to the thing and just look
around oh you got drugs have your first
inning go get a hot dog and you men
going you'll bump into street people hey
man can I get you a hot dog right away
Hank come in I'll get you two hot dogs
who's on the way the right hand and
they'll tell you right then I'll go but
there's no weed but that guy's got
[ __ ] in the valium and that guy's got
Hamlin whoa boom that's how easy it is
that's how you gotta go onto the help
there's no yell yeah there's no yell for
drug dealing when you just get to a town
so that it pissed me off that this kid
hits me and you know when somebody hits
you probably be a lot of those people
that come up to you and they want some
but they just don't tell you yeah always
like I brought you this and you're like
I don't need that I just tell me what
the [ __ ] it is that you want like a year
I go what's the [ __ ] what's the problem
don't know he says to me I really want
to be famous
what yeah and I really want to get out
of here you know you could just hum I
can't I don't know nobody what do I know
cool side for me then it keeps hitting
me like with little tags and [ __ ] I
don't know you know there's two types of
people like when I go to Burke Rice's
house he invites me over for his
daughter's dynasound when I go over
there and I thought we paid I want you
to know I appreciate this [ __ ] like I
hate and I go over there there's two
types of
there's people that like people like
that house and there's people don't like
people at the house
among those mother I don't like be by my
house you know if you come over I want
you to act like a civilized person don't
be yelling and screaming you know I
don't want nobody either you don't
nobody in the house Felipe I have an
office at my house I didn't do the
podcast in my house it's safe 700 but
you know I don't want my [ __ ] oh yeah
you need 50 for it me or some agree with
you but don't talk to my [ __ ] else
they'll be knocking each year no I'll
let you know when it's time to come home
my [ __ ] house I'll let you know I'm
one of those do it he call it like about
a month ago he started with that [ __ ]
like if we could just get some help and
I finally had a shine and Alice listen
there's no help bro you a young guy go
stealing I just need help to get out of
here what do you think I did to get out
of New Jersey you think I just worked
now I did when you did I worked
something doing fruit for two nights I
said this is [ __ ] slave labor and I
went and borrowed money from along
you're gonna let him [ __ ] a down man
who gives a [ __ ] that's how you make a
move so you make sure you don't come
back I was in the Midwest you put
yourself in a position so you can make
sure you don't come back crazy man
I was in the Midwest and I hung out with
some comics you know like in the Midwest
and then later on man the this comic I
just made goes a man now I'm a beak
coming to our labor man did a good crash
at your house right they lovely
hell no least I'm telling you the truth
I got a daughter I got a life every room
you come over Lee Felipe's come over
where'd you come I don't know these
people and I finally had to send them an
email go on first off bro before you
give me any attitude I don't know you
yeah I don't know you you want from me I
don't know you you know I get how many
Polly but how many people con you here I
tell these [ __ ] you know I was telling
about a month ago
leave said that you spoke to some guy
about a job and the guy wanted a highly
to sell content to put on a website like
only you don't want to do that illegal
or not I go cuz Lee every comic that's a
friend
has already been terrorized it's the
last thing we want to do with a million
great ideas with a million great idea
and to give up our content because guess
what at the end of the day we don't get
paid that's all your emails that's
[ __ ]
with nobody gets a dime ya wanna get all
the content if you could give us all you
and you give them videos and there's no
money
guess who's swallowing the YouTube they
are all these people the Laugh Factory
just hit me about three months ago hi we
want to put your video up note because
for what I don't get nothing right you
tell me I'm gonna get some I don't get
none now with the laughs Boston I did
that comedy that the people take my set
and can we put it on our website we'll
pay your percentage I want to buy a year
got a million things No so nobody wants
to hear nothing don't come to us with no
scam so I told them I said don't go to
these comics with scam way they're not
gonna talk to you but I got they gonna
turn their back we got scammed with the
CD they saw the army and a DVD and the
DVD millions we've been scanned Jose
Diaz they paid off man i'ma say man 300
they paid all the cash and check and
then when they went Joe Diaz till that
guy all right man
but Joe Diaz got the money in a check he
told I got his face
see you never again come back I never
gonna come back and that's that was
aired everywhere bro that tape that was
that we were I row 9/11 we did that
before 9/11 and what the people did was
there's a commissary over and when Iraq
or Iran or ever they went and that was
the Lord when Filipinos that wasn't my
number that was the number one video
that they were selling because I was
seeing soldiers on the street and they
would come up to me and go bro
Gina you made my [ __ ] stage so much
easier with that tape and I remember I
got the longest yard and I was so pissed
I took money from The Longest Yard high
an attorney I was telling me the other
day that there was a time I didn't have
a very good relationship with the
Icehouse we corner Bob fish at the mall
wanted there you go there you go legal
with you I don't [ __ ] around man you
always money if I give you
I don't know how you and I were at the
mall we stopped officially we didn't
watch no chamber picture whatever to
that [ __ ] I'm comedy piccata money or
whatever it was his face got purple yeah
I never got any money yes you did yes
you [ __ ] did you got money now we
want our [ __ ] money so for a long
time I didn't have a good relationship
with the Izod cuz I kept telling them up
next time I say I'm a [ __ ] strangle
you we're going to get a dime all of us
split a dime together yeah I guess and
when I found out but but I found out by
a guy in the Navy was there was a guy
that was burning that particular DVD was
Joe Diaz mean him the devil and picked
on lap and I think I don't know Edwin
but he was [ __ ] he made a bunch of
copies and he was like sending them to
the officer for five bucks
we got killed on that but you know what
you make it up later on if it's meant to
be it's meant to be don't cry over spilt
milk he's never happy though man
no you're never happier for that's why I
tell people when they come to me with
that stuff now you know what I love you
but I don't want no involvement I don't
want no Imam and especially when it's a
comic Oh
comes up to you like somebody who's
friends with a comic and they come up to
you with this camp your blood pressure
gets boiling you're like I see this
common already I don't like it like
we're doing like the bowling attica
media wasn't here the guys do the
bowling alleys and what time he recorded
all he was selling your DVD well Rick
Martinez Rick Martinez I totally about
it another one Lee he's the guy that
taught me how to show everyone you
should sell DVDs and I go I don't have
one I have one we don't have an open it
off your opener we did teeth you know a
wider look at you old [ __ ] school
honey this is his Chuck Bronson right
here bro I'm not [ __ ] around [ __ ]
around there go
he needs that beer bed let me give some
shoutouts real quick over bro
I wasn't applying your little vegan
glasses I like those [ __ ] there was a
relative Woodrow you gotta either be my
man Tyler binoy [ __ ] family den Fred
berry man Cod man Daniel Wheatley Shawn
Welsh ought to ass with my brother from
Staten Island
Anthony Z Bradley Andale mimosa papi and
Canadian [ __ ] Bronco
baby I want to give you a little [ __ ]
some lovin here you know maybe here to
get your stunt on the right foot and
don't forget next Thursday night the
18th I'm headed with the [ __ ] Nazi
killer with my main man the Nazi killer
Lisa at into Austin Texas will be at cap
city Friday's half waking on Saturdays
gun all you got is Friday early and
Thursday fun there and the Charlotte
comedies on the farm on Thursday at 25th
I'll see you savages there tip top Magoo
ready to go smoking reefer and [ __ ]
eating the best food and Buckman
Charlotte and that's it [ __ ]
you know I'm saying my man Felipe is
gonna be in New York City next weekend
what's the day I'm gonna be there this
Saturday at the saddle this Saturday
this Saturday yeah this January 13th the
day the devil was buried at sea where
you gonna be performin be that thumb at
the PlayStation theater one show eight
o'clock
we have a special host Louie Guzman bro
okay from bully nights send them my love
my anger I shot the pilot for the Luis
Guzman show did you know that I shot the
pilot for that me and I think Rudy yeah
Rudy Moreno and this other dude we shot
the pilot I shot the pilot Louie didn't
like me a little no I got until a fight
with the [ __ ] director does he kept
my it was a [ __ ] god-awful show yeah
god-awful it was God let me tell bad how
bad was it that my wife who doesn't say
a bad word about anybody told me on the
ride home boy boy I don't think that
shows when I get picked up I'll be
looking at is shocked at first and going
you saw that too it was god-awful it was
written horribly that was the first time
I realized Fox doesn't have a [ __ ]
bat lo of what the [ __ ] dead don't you
know when new people when I say little
things and you'd be my gotta find it
about a network or some bait it's cuz
I've gone that [ __ ] over and I walked
around I build on a couple of their
shows and I gotta tell you some bro I've
been burn more from Fox than anything
and no shows a [ __ ] brutal and every
time you shoot for Fox they put you
further and further into the [ __ ]
dungeon watch is my luck tomorrow I have
a [ __ ] audition with Fox and they'll
say to me or would you start a [ __ ]
bad gas but it's true my body got picked
up by Fox yah my pilot didn't yeah about
I don't remember I don't know if I'm
story involved because I think I'm now
I'm ever Longoria's attached with the
same showrunners and doesn't he borrow
at night so we'll see what happens man
oh good I took that back from Fox and
Fox isn't exposure right above some
networks man don't they look alike when
they go on the head writer and Latino
Latino show might be a white guy man
you're like he thrown Detroit
I know Latino yeah but but you know
Midwestern Latinos what you know about
West Coast you know I know that's what
you know wha they just were you lose man
during in a lowrider and having the lead
actor
fallen over the white shake is a good
formula but not everybody not buddy else
the white see if you have it on YouTube
the Luis Guzman show see if you have it
on YouTube just so here's the problem
for me we'll be there at that show on
later this this Saturday the Saturday
night PlayStation T the Wizzle located
it's located in Manhattan Manhattan
there you go you take it from [ __ ]
little beach was real torus Luis Guzman
myself
Toby Hicks and much of Rizzo bro you
taking my hell yeah you take ever been
there you're taking the whole [ __ ]
crew with him bro
Gabriel style you taking a [ __ ]
with you telling you bro last year yeah
give back I hear you're gonna give her a
little the didn't come here a little
taste bro to give him hope he's still
booking commercials Rizzo lookie
something bro is he does like an
after-school program what he teaches art
nah there's nothing there yeah in
January I'm 19 I'm gonna be at the
Jumeirah pasa I'm gonna have breakfast
and I'm selling tickets to my show at
the Nova theater March 23rd
that's a nice boys probably know what it
is bro I don't want to
third and hopefully that'll do well and
I'd march 24th also but um a lot of
times you know people don't wanna pay
the surcharges so I put a minute on Sam
Boyle Heights I'm gonna be there selling
the actual ticket for the show at the
right price no taxes think all the taxes
already included but no surcharge your
swim you're gonna be paid thirty dollars
just for the ticket it will never be 40
50 55 it's gonna be the exact price
thirty bucks and I'll have my vinyl
there I have unloaded to my biner
know you didn't bring it when I saw it I
saw it Stephan well it's in a mill okay
um I'm gonna I'll bring a purse in the
car in the car I've got a bio of my
special I'll translate this so your
special did well a lot of people going
to see it was great yeah you know what
um a lot of people coming up to me say
they liked it i'm i'm so very surprised
that Tom Rhodes and she saw him and his
girlfriend sounds cool ain't nobody
[ __ ] strong we went you were very
generous and invited Pauling out of your
premiere but I fled to Terry but least
Lisa ate more vegan taco the regular
taco at that party I know he fell in
love bro he don't want to tell you huh
but they were delicious bro vegan gold
you had oh so those that sacrilegious
for this vaporize delicious
sacrilegious raw it does vegan goat bro
you love them wrong I love this guy food
in the world huh huh if he tells you you
like something it's bad it's really bad
bro
what him and his girlfriend like I would
blow your mind with any team and they
look at each other and clap and smile
when they read this laugh some other
people look at that [ __ ] and go I want
my [ __ ] money back they have you like
delis you know George right no he don't
like that lease he likes cuz I saw this
27 where I told that what the [ __ ] oh he
likes tongue
he likes to talk I don't know he will
need them or anything good time other
than one one little tongue I used to eat
i'm totaku though you have no idea and
if he tore that tofu was good it
probably was to him and you're eating it
too like the [ __ ] more that you are
eating that [ __ ] the list I just saw
somebody there was a Fidesz Oh
around Weight Watchers that you put a
slice of tofu what Oh
why would you put like a marinated tofu
on a [ __ ] piece of burger delicious
if you sold that [ __ ] at a restaurant I
would not step into your [ __ ]
restaurant at all
if I fall that you have tofu burnt or I
don't get it I just don't get it I don't
understand
oh man and you're Mexican that's what
kills me over here Boulder we are in awe
that's your heaven we walked into a raw
restaurant only Vigo ordered our raw
meaning slice slider and it was all made
with raw floor nothing was cooked the
raw burger it was like how the the bread
was made out of like this toasty bread
and the mirror was like beans and the
cheese was bare - cashew and the ketchup
laid Naturals tomato do nothing was
cooked or do you go hated it
no but he ate some tacos next time you
go to Boulder you just call me and go on
water Boulder in two days that's all
notice I need just other good to open a
carriage Esther no I'm gonna hook you up
with one of the finest people and cooks
mmm my life and Tony are a lot easier
that's all you need to know that's all
you need to do he had three brothers he
had three brothers one ran a restaurant
in Miami the other one in San Francisco
the other one emboldened the other one
in New York one of those towns like
sound like get doing and that's exactly
what they did when the cops are looking
for him they all jumped on a ship they
shot they got on sailboats and they went
around the world to evade capacitation
broad capital prosecution prosecution
and I had a deal with the government I
met him when they cut a deal with the
government I met the wife first when she
was running the restaurant and then I
was in the halfway house with the
husband and then we became [ __ ]
goombah till today I still call he's
Italian and he speaks better and Spanish
than the both of you [ __ ] the clients
that's how real he is he's small and on
his restaurant menu he was on Fridays
would be the Cuban food or Mexican food
and he would cook it and your [ __ ]
head would blow up he's got a restaurant
now but I would have sent you down
late to the farmers market where he
makes pizza by hand and you got back to
me he's about 80 now he's old
I just talked to him a couple months ago
he's my dog's that's where I would have
sent you a boner I don't think you can
have it what do you think you have one
you can't have the pizza cuz of the egg
right
no the cheese oh that's a [ __ ] man you
eat it that's how Antonio look dzo gives
a [ __ ] inside Tyree needs up you read
royalty I'm sayin one day you get away
from me in that billy goat food and
[ __ ] get a [ __ ] some protein in you
[ __ ] tofu and [ __ ] foo and that [ __ ]
there how much [ __ ] good food there
isn't bothering you eating a raw [ __ ]
burger I would have put roller skates on
him left him and taupe and Toby Hicks
you really be ashamed of himself because
he's black from Omaha from Omaha the
land the [ __ ] steaks he was the only
black dude I know this bro the only
[ __ ] black people bald with football
players and my taking out a line they
beat on them too they've been beating on
those people for years I tell you the
reason why I got away with my beef
biggest beef from Boulder the biggest
thing I ever did when I had two felonies
was to smack my ex-girlfriends husband
for calling me aspect and I got away
with because in the city of limit milem
it's a boulder you can't use a racial
slur in Boulder because of the black
football players they got tortured so
much one owned JJ Flanagan punched a
chick in the [ __ ] eye and doctor I
Alice and something [ __ ] crazy so you
can't [ __ ] we use racial slurs to
seal him it's a bowl they probably
changed it by now after John when they
[ __ ] anything goes we kill the kid at
this point who gives a [ __ ] about black
people hey no no you don't know a
[ __ ] ball that you never know I don't
[ __ ] it no you don't say what's the
matter we do some bulls anybody's how I
was gonna be in um I'm gonna Hawaii man
with Paul's Regas are usually hello
hello and Honolulu Aloha I love her
hydrated shut up - Andy bhumata legend
man genno and the [ __ ] boomer tires
go to Colorado Lee I drove through it
once on the way here to stop and Denver
Yeah right at a motel 6 right I was at
them that's it I was driving here
yeah I've always wanted to go back it
seems nice it seems very don't know it's
like I told you guys for this guys they
got the legalize weed
yeah weed story told you in the
beginning of the podcast at sunset
herbal the home of the stars they open
from 6:00 a.m. now that worth attend a
[ __ ] o'clock at night go see my girl
sky she's gonna work from 6:00 a.m.
every day the - they gotta serve bagels
I mean they're gonna [ __ ] big over
that but guess what people let me tell
you what California got themselves into
so for a $60 bag of weed it's sixteen
dollars attacks so a $60 bag of weed now
cost you seventy six dollars they don't
really charge me I just had to tell them
what I want and they give me a number
and I give it to when I dip the girls
but sixty sixteen dollars on $60 worth
of marijuana and I think even wanna you
[ __ ] got it you [ __ ] dummies I
think in Nevada it's closer to 100
percent is that like taxes oh I know
that I can't Colorado at their 25
percent review 20%
limitation there's one weeds do I go
into when I do the comedy works cuz
they're very nice people that's the one
by the Condor on the corner you don't
think the Condor do you know you go
downstairs no I'm gonna hold yeah yeah
go upstairs real clean right nice nice
people
yeah I live with that one I go to that
when they take care of me Joe is tell
you Dave Chappelle was here you know do
they always tell me that
well Drigo tour is over here I guess how
would you go tour is like I said rare
right generally what like I said 16 like
I said in the beginning of yeah this
can't become a promotion show Hawaii
just promote who you are just New York
I knew your that's way but knew your
Saturday Hawaii and this guy inbred whoa
what the [ __ ] is going on in but it's
really crazy when now that razor we were
here for the [ __ ] regular weed you
know for the first boom and it was very
interesting and now words become and
even with this [ __ ] Colorado thing
you know like now I got like I said when
I go to Colorado I don't even bother
going to [ __ ] weed stores because I
bring my own [ __ ] but wow that's the
first time I got killed one of these
[ __ ] things this morning I was wrong
it's 15% look we're in Vegas Nevada
Nevada I thought it was more not can't
be on how you gonna go spend a Halloween
huh you gotta be a [ __ ] [ __ ] to even
walk in there you really gotta be a
[ __ ] tourist or walking there I want
to do something like that that just said
anything and that's what they're guiding
it for listen California is pointing
that - just like Colorado there's
nothing to do the same thing and guess
what if you think Colorado was [ __ ]
you
California's gonna bang you up the ass
twice they don't give a [ __ ] it's tough
to get that license and it's tough to do
all this [ __ ] they're making these girls
six in the [ __ ] morning - ten o'clock
at night is that necessary is that
[ __ ] necessary even I don't need a
we've store open the [ __ ] six even me
how to lead a weed store but it's sex
I'm alright I always have a little
something for the mouse in the morning
you know if you got a mouse in the
morning you ain't [ __ ] real Jesus now
when are you planning on shooting
another special Phillipe um my deal with
HBO is two years so probably in two
years so your shoot one in two more
years yes
hopefully it'll be with HBO or I'll get
a better deal with somebody or hopefully
HBO and I want what I want to do I want
to host a stand-up show where I could
showcase comedians you know like I'm not
telling I wouldn't wear now I gave her
head standing revolution you know I
wanna do a show like that something
original original yes yes Callie hey
that's not bringing up [ __ ]
Oh what can you do can you do an
explosion in between can you shoot a
comic that's why they don't freak show
bro that's why the networks don't do it
no more because it became like this
[ __ ] I always thought it would change
to to cater I'll piss my kitchen like
something - to make a difference Mike
but then we never came up with nothing
better then one god okay locos you know
look at like the Rodney special stay
with a appended no comedians they're
young comedians that's what but not
everybody they didn't put up a thousand
people though just six sick all year and
well it wasn't like a series that were
they [ __ ] up many comics get hot every
year there's comics to the working
comics I'm a working time overtime huh
my comic yeah I'm a working comic those
days are over with a hot comic is
chappal it's [ __ ] lukewarm Sebastian
that's [ __ ] bill burr damn comics
yeah well I don't I don't care about
that I'm Kevin I'm Kevin Huong a girl
I'm fortunate to be [ __ ] working
I'm very fortunate just to be [ __ ]
working but I'm gonna make sure six
comics is a year that's what comes out
of [ __ ] anyways since comics say yeah
you know when you watch that when you
want what young comedians in the one rod
and he did with the already established
guys was something different see that
that's a nice one well he did with
Seinfeld and pics and clay SAP Kinnison
Kennison Lenny Clarke of a Kip okay go
away Bob no that wasn't Robert Ellison
Robert Townsend and the the gate kid
little jacket no Jay yes
Jeff Walton was on that way that's right
Jeff Waldman Robert Rimmel
yeah all the Chimel was on those and I
got Jeff what what they gave the mask
man it was good bro tell people how good
the [ __ ] was Jeff what what hi
Fox so if you were to go to the bar
scene what you gonna do is my name is
Jeffy Jeff Jeff Jeff Jeffrey James Jim
what what who's talking to that [ __ ]
we're in special he had the football
play yeah see it's weed who the mom the
mom
the most outstanding ones were Jeffrey
Jeffrey Jeffrey little cross-eyed and
[ __ ] knob and it's funny you know
reminds me of Jeffrey Jeff and all that
guy you know it was like a Rick be the
big potato have you were correct no that
is Rick D potato I think he's a Staten
Island guy but he's New Jersey's got a
lot of videos on YouTube funny
[ __ ]
Malaysian he's a garbage man New York
and he's a father you know he has a bro
I worked with him 15 years ago
Felipe he's a writer like you he took me
to the [ __ ] cleaners with a joke
about taking his family to Florida with
four kids in the car talking I was in
the back I couldn't [ __ ] breathe I
couldn't [ __ ] breathe yeah he's one
of those comics he's been around for
thirty years you know another guy he's a
working town yeah he's not a hot calling
he's a working comic it's really like
though let the comedian like you never
seen his glad in a podcast you know him
do 20 podcasts just can't hardly had an
email or yahoo or it's not even an AOL
call did nothing but they're hilarious
and hilarious see what are you doing you
know like like I would with a guy named
Chuck Martel you know he opened up for
me and I found out the he I opened up
for Nick Swardson and Tom papa I
couldn't find his phone number I saw
Murtaugh I saw him I thought comedy
magic once and I call the Laugh Factory
Tom Papa called him I called him here
when I we did a bunch of shows together
in Ventura Chicago now he's gone again I
can't find him but this guy's hilarious
bro he had the job where he says that um
they say that sometimes
fireworks gunshots unlike fireworks so
last year during fourth of July my
neighbor killed and shot his whole
family and I'm outside my house with a
hot dog singing god Bless America see
what this guy's dark and now he's pretty
funny man but you know one of those guys
he's just a working comic shuttle hotel
here's the problem that you have Felipe
see when I got him to calm me I got into
County to hide like I got into comedy to
be like an outlaw comic like I was just
going to do comedy from down
do drugs sleep and that's it that was it
I didn't want much I didn't want a
webpage it's it's and I've said this a
thousand times I really don't like when
people develop an ally because it puts
too much unnecessary stress on you do
you have a headshot you have a website
still your back is I'm a manager you
want to be you know I want to be in a
Chelsea well how many followers you got
you just [ __ ] started calm me if you
start comedy in Michigan you don't talk
about headshots
you just talk about family yeah that's
good for Minnesota you just talk about
calming that's it when you start comedy
in Boston chuckle my family nobody goes
hey man there's an agent looking for
people to be on a TV show you don't
think about that outside [ __ ] that's
only here yeah so it [ __ ] you up in a
way I'm very happy I didn't develop here
because they're already talking to you
about developmental deals at the
two-year mark he didn't even have the
fundamentals I had to hold him [ __ ]
microphone so that's what I like you
know like anything else you gotta have
the [ __ ] basics in you you know
Felipe got basics you got basics I mean
you learned from you were around old
schoolers but if you want you would
watch young comics and then I don't have
the basics down there was drinking her
hand for five minutes it's like they put
a drink up as a prop to try to throw you
off this Lord I'm 25 years old
I've never brought a cocktail up on
stage do you know that even in my
[ __ ] craziness I've never brought a
cocktail up on stage I think that's
offensive I think that's really [ __ ]
offensive unless you're Ron White yeah
yeah unless you're somebody like that
it's your show you want to bring a
[ __ ] picture up go but if you're
faking it like to be cool to pick up
chicks and they stir the drink on there
yeah tries me [ __ ] crazy oh that's
not comedy that has nothing to do with
calm you don't take the drink up there
when they bring a beer in their hand and
we do maintain bond up their diet or the
audience the club all dislike it because
you're promoting the beer and people see
that you're drinking so they sell extra
beer I don't give a [ __ ] about that
I'm worried about my comedy I'm worried
about doing [ __ ] calm I'm worried
about giving them the best show I could
give them that's the differences that's
why I don't bring that [ __ ] up there so
many tricks people do another doctor
some of them are doing a comedy and
they're kind of like dance you know
they're beer like moving around with it
I hate that [ __ ] and I'm a [ __ ]
junkie you know I never you know it's
like I would love see I would love to go
onstage and bring a join up watched a
it's oddly - man give me three joints I
don't my sets over well is it all and
I've smoked the half but you know I'm
saying cuz I won't smoke the whole joint
you'll smoke a half but for me no Ethan
my next special if I don't do this with
Netflix and Netflix says no to me really
doesn't bother me because in my next
special I'm gonna do each one a quarter
is gonna be called three joints the sets
up we'll the three joints a gun
I'll find the place to let me smoke pot
even if it's the fourth wall a little
[ __ ] I don't give a [ __ ]
that's that'd be fun yeah that's it this
sets over when you smoke three joints
that's it
that's my next comedy special and then I
retire from this [ __ ] oh I die I
get hit by a car like that video but
[ __ ] it happening let me tell you
something that [ __ ] what's that crazy
dude from Miami that puts all the videos
up and [ __ ] have you seen his last video
he put up okay
I know the [ __ ] guy from Miami they
used to call into the podcast the
producer daniel Corbin there have you
seen Billy call Billy Gore video he put
up about some guy got 20 years for
hitting a kid on a scooter and they show
the guy getting hit on a [ __ ] cowboy
huh the guy who did cocaine Cowboys put
up a video yesterday Oh some guy like on
a scooter at night whistling down this
feeling like one of those Spanish dudes
I'd take those beats things at night
you're driving you see like those
Mexicans on a bicycle and a second rope
and a [ __ ] drunk driver just clocks
this [ __ ] guy with this truck I mean
think I lived this [ __ ] there was a
bunch of people walking they ran save
them - people come out of that Park
see if you can find the video listen the
guy was like oh that guy got hit he's
[ __ ] he was skidding on the side way
if that guy dies bro so many cuts is
like that's taken
that's how you get a steak I'm gonna do
leg fall off after an accident some guy
just happens to be there picks up that
legs and runs with a jack oh my god so
true I know lie to you dog is it that
show put on the Big C just listen to
Billy's tweet Miami prostitute and
passenger seat in car just put the video
on will show the Filipe he's gonna
[ __ ] die look at this [ __ ] dawg he
clocks this dude heavy-duty I mean poor
guy got rest his soul or whatever look
at the do that again and you know what's
sad it's only got 24 it Guterres looking
up he looks like a lot of people Robert
Velasco was since a Tuesday the 20 years
in prison for the crash a hooker and his
call was to stop witness at the trial
I've been blowing here when the whole
thing went down
look at this [ __ ] bro let me just put
bastard look at a little different angle
huh no but same angle oh my god thank
God that guy's that would have killed me
Kyle fat robber over left who was said
Tuesday 20 years and please this is why
guys this is why I won't leave wanna get
a bicycle I voted against it you want to
ride a bicycle go to the [ __ ] 24-hour
fitness and you get on that little
scooter and you ride all you want with
the helmet on and I'll put a sticker on
your helmet but you're a dumb [ __ ] you
drive your bicycle in the wrong places
bro this is what happens to you yeah
it's not that I'm anti bison why don't I
don't trust people on the [ __ ] roads
and this is the reason why I trust you I
trust me on a bicycle I just don't trust
anybody else and that can happen I know
two people all [ __ ] up on bicycles
right here in Studio City right here
trying to be cute riding their bicycles
one chick from yoga got blasted at night
I look like oh you really ride your bike
at night yeah it's okay there's a bike
path okay is that safe it don't matter
somewhere how do you get to the bike
path you gotta walk that bison just
drive to the bike path you know we have
the one drive to the bike path he enjoys
in the morning you see it I got a deal
with anything
the calorie is [ __ ] right by the
mouth that boy who takes the bathroom
saying dear that's my point
it's on the way to the [ __ ] bike path
where you get clocked but that's [ __ ]
all right that's all it's trying to
avoid this is why I don't know you want
to ride a bicycle
get yourself a little bicycle and put on
your balcony your vitamin D at the same
time that's the answer the vitamin D but
to ride a bike on the street who the
[ __ ] are you kidding you have a hard
time walking you only thousand a day
time he didn't leave the house for 2:30
yesterday's poor bastard you rent a bike
no you know I have no [ __ ] another
chariot
I brought a bike when I was up north so
that we can figure in my love for it me
so you know what Lord say knows it you
wrote a bike yeah they have bikes just
hanging out at Google because Google is
so big so you just get on a bicycle
yeah we just got a little Java home no
let's Gary good chance I didn't I didn't
go on the street I just want through
their parking lots yeah it's an animal
it's I don't [ __ ] like it I don't
[ __ ] like it at all
motorcycles you going on the 405 and you
see those [ __ ] scooters replying by
in the HOV Lane and you like bro one
damn he's gonna be coming flying I would
never do that and if you're riding the
bicycle and want to say you know I love
you and I care for you and I'm not
saying done the negative light but the
odds are always against you especially
now especially in California with these
[ __ ] people every morning I wake up
and somebody's getting hit by a car
there's a hit-and-run three mornings a
week there's a hit-and-run in California
and it's always in the shitty
neighborhoods it's all and it's always
somebody [ __ ] nicest [ __ ] a
grandmother who goes to get a gallon of
milk and 11 for our grandchildren or
something it's never like some [ __ ]
gang members or nothing it's always like
somebody who did something nice that
gets whacked by a [ __ ] car in the
middle of night no no no no that right
I'm the [ __ ] bike back I don't even
like listen I've become so [ __ ] I
used to walk around New York City for
years with earphones on with the Walkman
nevertheless I am petrified to walk
around the park with earphones on I
can't hear somebody sneak up my donut I
always have morning everybody in one
year but out yeah
I don't want to do that here cuz I'm
hearing birds and kids yelling Sophia
who needs that [ __ ] I don't want to hear
birds and kids y'all and that's a forest
around me you have to fully it might be
round round I'm [ __ ] that I want to
hear [ __ ] I don't want to hear some
[ __ ] okay I want to hear music but
I've become so paranoid about my
surroundings in my older age because
people don't give a [ __ ] people don't
really give a [ __ ] so you could be
walking like somebody come up to you and
stab you with a sword and next thing you
know that they don't like white people
yeah they don't like white people or
something here comes the Calvary eight
guys and if you're not walking around
looking for that this there's something
wrong with you every day and especially
like ever you gonna New York look at
[ __ ] New York it's always drama yes
I'm a guy who the hammer on YouTube
somebody just told me they went to the
hall John but John bug doesn't happen
Jang bogos every day there's something
different on the subway he goes that is
a [ __ ] nightmare
John bud went back bro and he says it
was the longest vacation of his life oh
my god I thought people listen you got a
girlfriend it's three days when you got
a girlfriend in a strange town it's
three days anything up to three days
you're looking for trouble especially in
New York that's a lot of walking a lot
of spending I ain't [ __ ] Pope the
honest you got three days to do what you
want to do they hate you at the Museum
of Natural History it is that this that
this that does that that's great that's
a great [ __ ] plan
but you better pick three and hold on
tight to that there's all this [ __ ] cost
money
and all this [ __ ] takes a lot of effort
he goes he was never so cold in his life
his girlfriend got sick he ended up
getting sick but I sent him talk to
happen he'll get [ __ ] Italian food he
said was because he was something all
those [ __ ] those traps down in Little
Italy
Sbarro it's amazing what birds are good
then trash I wouldn't go there
cuz there's thing outside that outside
the restaurant like Italian when I gave
then every no I don't leave Italy no
good food I don't go now that I looked
at on Mulberry no I go to that I go you
want real Italian yeah real [ __ ] I'm
Italian gonna make a reservation when
you leave here for Mario's or all the
one next one I can't remember
ought to have it all in the Bronx that's
the last gem listen to me that's the
last jet more than a mobile
Oh yet little burr is just a bunch of
tourists go down I see The Sopranos or
what John Gotti was or whatever that's
done those days are done solo best run
they're always been bad they no no they
are gonna glue it out what Dominic's
they were good at one time but they sold
them to somebody else that's what those
people were gangsters don't get where
the gangsters they're in jail they're
dead so they saw Tom Nexus cash only
yeah that's how good that [ __ ] place
it beau just go to our family do not
waste your time and they were house
anymore
get Mario's get that bread from the
Bronx get that bread from the Bronx
learn with good [ __ ] bread is when
you break that bread from the Bronx this
is Bret this is as good as it's gonna
get you know some olive oil
whatever butter I was wondering tofu
whatever the [ __ ] he's gonna he gonna
ruin it anyway you gonna [ __ ] that meal
that money way I wouldn't take you to
marry us cuz you're gonna [ __ ]
depress me in there at some point and
your hair pasta what do you eat what do
you eat engineer pasta spaghetti sauce
angel hair pasta is nothing else you
know now I wouldn't even waste my time
taking the [ __ ] the slaw boss where
is he Mauro stauros that's where you
belong vegan you can't go down and get a
meatball how about those dailies man
those cats that what are you gonna be
there catid alleys closed
yeah yeah what do you need that you can
eat salami right no so what do you
always people's time for donut man
insulting them avocado toast no don't go
in there go to someplace I love toast
why are you wasting people's time with
that Barry they know you're part of the
church be coming then you oughta have a
kind of dose it gets back to me and then
my feelings get hurt
I'm saying whatever the Chloe's you
wanted to die I go to Chloe's or some
Hindu vegan place where we love the
[ __ ] you know the flaming tofu oh you
would you grateful what to the vegan
restaurant one time and the waiter they
had they ask you they tell you they ask
you before you eat what are you grateful
for for you [ __ ] is getting shot
that's wrong a restaurant awaits you a
way to come out through hybrid suit um
what are you grateful for that's where I
get up that's why I don't go to dinner
parties
have you been to identify in the last
two years never three years there's a
new thing with white people
they all look around each other 19
people they don't want to say at one
point get up and say what you're
grateful for you know what I did that
this morning or our man I sent it
directly to God why am I gonna say it to
19 people gonna hit 19 here beans before
I bite into this [ __ ] salad number
one I walked in the door hungry and you
had a tofu planet with [ __ ] nah there
was no salami there was no nothing you
ever go to those parties where you spill
its own and they got no [ __ ] food and
now they served like an hour later and
you gotta wait an hour to [ __ ] eat
and you're already forget it I don't
know I don't want to know nothing what
are you grateful for you know what like
and you that you asked me that question
cuz now I can get up and get the [ __ ]
out of here
that's why can that stand data parties
where there's more than four people on
the table I avoid those like the playing
dog that's what people doing [ __ ] my
moderate partner not monitoring wait
here no no no no they all go to the west
side all the people and of Santa Monica
they always have dinner parties won't
you come the topic will be love listen
leave me the [ __ ] alone because number
two you know what else they do they
measure food and nothing insults me more
them in your to somebody's house and
they measure food by people working the
river and you have another somebody's
house and they were a chef or something
they measure [ __ ] food you want to
piss me off measure food I'm taking what
I want maybe I don't like the corn wait
maybe I don't like the [ __ ] corn not
everything is like buffet style Joe not
anything is one man is dead gonna invite
me to your house they don't invite me to
you I said my wife my wife went to
pornos this morning to get some [ __ ] by
the way you're invited you always all
invited the parks at 11:00 she calls me
she goes hang out for tea potatoes I got
this forty [ __ ] people get mainly
balls I want to throw away food yeah I
want to throw away [ __ ] food he's I'm
saying like what yeah but you're gonna
party they run out of food that's an
insult to me though yeah that's an
insult to me you just insulted okay no
more shrimp are you from yeah and then
go get more go get more you know how can
you have a partial when I have a party
I'm gonna throw away food I was
it's a birthday it's a birthday I want
anybody go crazy there's only one
birthday a [ __ ] year she's only gonna
add this once like I said I might be
dead in two [ __ ] years I gotta
celebrate these birthdays well I got him
so truth bro nobody sends EE tells you
when the Grim Reaper's coming in I'm
saying there's two tonight like no
there's only one person who he was
getting shot that was Kelly he was
waving Kelly was the only guy was waving
why he got shot he knew he knew that he
was the real psychic of them all hey if
you're gonna drop knowledge in the drop
knowledge I'm saying it's good to see
you Felipe good to see you guys too man
happy you can't help it Elena you having
talked I'm happy we spoke about the
journey of commie mommy MIG Perret well
not even Jean perenna I just want people
to know that like I said I've been doing
and I'm not even from LA that's the
scary thing
I'm not even fun of LA if I was would
have been from LA I would have been
there when he got on stage the first
time but that's just to show you guys
that when you go to your little [ __ ]
open mics and you're a little frustrated
and you don't know that out of the 12
people in that room three you guys are
gonna be [ __ ] stars and it's not gonna
be it's not gonna be a big mystery to
who it's going to be those stars it's
the people that stuck with it and took
it seriously that's that's amazing story
for anybody that you don't I never knew
that that's what that that's the first
place when did you meet Willy I met with
Lee in 1990 and like in the 19 late let
me I got my first TV created in 1996
what was it let's you know laugh at the
Bulge of all dares and gradually that
was that yeah I got that one and I met
the Armada of the Waldos comedy station
and they were doing comedy at the
Hollywood hotel room and I met Willie
Barcena and I met Johnny Sanchez first I
met Johnny Sanchez first and then I made
um Willie Barcena at the the same comedy
show on a Saturday night you were
wearing our Dodger shirt a Dodger hat
and he came out to me and say what's up
man you're from Boyle Heights upper
Boyle Heights we should have lunch bro
but I don't know [ __ ] about no man
asking you for lunch so I thought like I
thought you were gay bro
so never call that food so now when you
were doing this in mind he finally got
mad when I finally called him did you
guys 9594 know you guys had a little
comedy quick Carlos had a little show
right yeah he had hosted a show called
comedy on Padre
Padres and comedy something 11 HBO and
but comedy compadres first and by 5 by
that time he had like Pablo he had a
couple people and that sort of a Cisco
they'll bring him about this Wow he had
that that Danny and his brother the
twins remember them yeah that's great I
remember beast being in Colorado
dreaming about being on that show and
then he got the show on HBO yeah
what was that called comedy local slam
and that was was yeah it was a good show
I remember I want to add the auditions I
would like that open mic and I saw
Freddy solo audition and he said hey hey
bro you should be auditioning but I had
no clue what's going on so like outside
watching iguana okay but I don't know
anybody in there and when were you
auditioning for I didn't audition
everyone was edition at The Comedy Store
for comedy picante no local slam hosted
by it by amp hosted by karma CR produced
by Nelly gallon poured Regan's and Java
audience for HBO it was supposed to be
the Latino version of Def Jam Def Jam at
the end they would wave the Paul
Rodriguez yeah for the USA oh and he
would tell us a goodbye on the bow but
other than I never was never on national
I did then I wanted to be on it oh my
god all right I wanted to be our culture
clash with Costa class was on but I'm I
didn't get a chance to a 96 it was weird
because after the culture clash thing
and they were only I remember even Luis
Guzman how's the buggy how's the buggy
was funny so there's all these Fox in
there was all these opportunities for
Latin OHS but broke I wasn't getting
them no and then when I came on it I
wasn't getting them either
you know it was cold so weird but these
guys befriended me and they didn't give
a [ __ ] that you know Paul finally put me
in that thing in the night Paul but Jeff
finally put me in funnier funny he's
seven and then we have funny is funny
she was a [ __ ] pain here you look
back at that [ __ ] now and if you look at
locals yeah it was no fun for me it was
really like I would do [ __ ] and they
wouldn't count me in nothing like yeah
no tour loved me but then they wouldn't
count me even in the trailer like I
would never be anyway you know like I'm
recently a guy kept bugging me to do
something about a year and a half ago
and I did it and he blew smoke up my ass
and the whole thing guess what the show
became a show bro
and he avoided me like a plague and then
when I did though the star moments of
the year he didn't put me in it's weird
and I just sit there and I giggle I go
you know what we're used to this [ __ ]
with tougher than nails we're still here
doing our [ __ ] thing who was part of
the scene in 97 97 was Carlos Alazraqui
from renown man 1 whereas Paulo
Francisco
although the Oscar he was pretty hard
Luke Taurus
luke tori her development deal and
Willie Barcena her development deal um I
think that's there was also um Willie
Barcena was headlining already and so
was part of at Cisco and there was I
think I'm few anybody else remember the
old Roberto Martinez Raul Martinez yeah
and of leaving La Rue de Marana break
down la big dumb laugh and the visual
chair is big dumb I went back so far he
was on Richard Pryor Richard Pryor show
from the roll show now what was the name
of the guy that took over for Freddie
Prinze when he got shot and then he used
to run the open mic at the Comedy Store
and he became a writer and acting coach
and you know people laughed at him when
no the Spanish dude who
that who taught vinny Colonel how to
write scripts and Vinnie colonel went on
to sell two scripts the boxer that can't
[ __ ] remember
Vinnie Colonel went on to sell two
scripts one to the vero
and the other one to Jack and Jill
tourist no it was a [ __ ] guy that took
over for Freddie Prinze see with his
name was Lee Fred the guy who took all
for Freddie Prinze and that nothing I
don't play pretty president movie row we
handle he was Queen Latifah's acting
coach for a while John Mercedes no
friends with John's anymore daddy Maura
Danny more identity coach yes he's an
acting coach in fact he was what's the
young guy that got married and [ __ ]
on his bachelor party [ __ ] the chicken
she divorced him Mario Mario he coaches
Mario he knew Mario's and man was a
[ __ ] kid he had married all those
[ __ ] years so then him more been
around Danny more anywhere I was around
before Park dude dad anymore as around
all of what Paul was there doing the
strike
yes during the communist or strike he
was lund doc who thought he was one of
Mitzi shore side Danny more or [ __ ]
took over for Freddie Prinze when he got
he killed himself that the anniversary
should be soon any day now what's the
anniversary for Freddie Prinze brother
should be if my memory still serves me
it was cold out in Jersey I think it was
January so when Freddie Prinze killed
himself
Danny Mora became Chico and Chico and
the man
29 he was way night the January right he
was I don't know that yeah anymore was
the Chicana my minute him he probably
did six episodes yeah handled it it was
tough to watch Chico a man after he
killed himself but Danny more anymore
was a very good man he was very good to
me he called me from time to time when
Rick Dunlap died he invited me to the
funeral but I lost contact with him I
really did I'd like to get him on the
show
if anybody knows that I gotta talk ago
Danny more yeah that's what I'll do I'll
call Willie yeah it had to be like I
haven't seen him I haven't spoken to
Amnon
what was that did you see him at
Willie's how long ago was the apology
display no I didn't see him over no he's
not part of that organization he was
dumb Danny more out during the
underworld on strike he was part of the
myth he were part of the hidden strike
with the comedian's he was like he said
[ __ ] that he's got never stood up for me
so he took them it's his life that's why
he still around
that's why she made him like a talent
coordinator she went Oildale off to the
Thor and loyal to Mitzi yeah
no no he was a good [ __ ] do it like
that no bro we come from good stock
Filipe we were very lucky and we met in
a pond anymore I needed you and you need
a man we came friends and I just won't
let people know man this ain't a [ __ ]
overnight thing we're talking to you you
think you sit there right now you know
[ __ ] 20 years I don't have 20 years
to become a comedian I need to do and
that's great you'll become a great
command in eight years
but it's not what long it it's not part
of the journey man the journey takes a
lot long and I tell you what when you're
doing comedy 20 years it's so sweeter it
really is a lot sweeter like you see the
game I'm like I know when I go to
jujitsu and I see those professors think
of [ __ ] and do [ __ ] and my tongue just
sits there hanging that's the way it is
for me with commie you know what else is
getting like that for me now acting bro
I've been acting for some long long now
that not to say this out of no
disrespect when I go on a set like I
[ __ ] know it like I [ __ ] know it
like I don't have to be told like I
don't know you know most cut oh Jesus
Christ
see that guy's still driving [ __ ] that
he's not in jail that's a guy who just
got hit by a bicycle feels a nobody
that's [ __ ] me but no man it's it's
always a pleasure to see you and it's
always a pleasure to see somebody who
paid his [ __ ] dues and can honestly
say nobody give a [ __ ] for me but nobody
gave a [ __ ] man you know like I called
my agent the other I go listen man when
Netflix tells you no I don't want you to
disappear he goes why would you say that
I go brokers I've done this town for 20
years they gonna they already had this
six people back
you know they want me to go through
hoops you know how long I mean I still
remember them reaching out to me for
Latino laughs festival and then telling
me to go [ __ ] myself
yeah years in a row they told me to go
[ __ ] myself they'll uh if I saw a comic
and I liked them and I walked up to him
and that it was my festival that means
our men I was minding my own business
when Jeff Valdez came up to me in
Seattle do you know that you do know
that right yeah no Jeff Valdez I saw we
used to have family in Seattle effect
from Denver yeah he's from death yes
from Colorado Springs but I saw him in
Seattle that's where he first saw him
you have to come here before you came to
our there way before I was there I think
I ended up here he's the one that came
up to me and said I got a project you're
perfect for it plus I got a festival I
like you to be part of the festival
maybe we'll do a Cuban thing and then he
I called him the next day at the hotel
and he met me for lunch
and he told me what his plans were and
then that was it and then also when they
had a call from some dude Pat buckles is
to tell Pat Boone the [ __ ] time I
talked to Jeff Bob Desmond Jeff on it
well you have to send the tape to Pat
buckles little [ __ ] bad buckles and
that's the first time and I told my the
guy who was kind of like my man in time
I go they're gonna give it to me why
would this guy come up to me Don they
turned you down then they turned me down
again in the second year then the third
year they included me but in the show of
Bobby Lee like an Asian Flair and I've
always told that one year you didn't
treat me right which I was really pissed
about was the year that he made me a
Marilyn audition the reason he almost
got what he got you were there that
night when I went down the reason why he
got [ __ ] his head banged against the
wall was because he did something really
bad man he made me and Marilyn showcase
like eight times for that festival then
he told us like that Thursday he'll tell
you what to wear - well it wasn't even
what the way he told us that he could we
couldn't say certain things and then he
told us a week before that we could not
her he was not gonna have the dirty show
and then the week of he had a true-blue
at midnight hosted by Carlos Mencia and
it was all clean comics
we're trying to work dirty but he
wouldn't put that's why I went crazy
that was the real reason because I felt
that he had [ __ ] me and Marilyn but I
recovered from it I wasn't that upset I
was obsessive maybe two days but it
really [ __ ] Marilyn up and then he
went back to Marilyn he is way that he
could put her in some stupid TV show he
was paying 250 bucks and yeah right he
was paying on what what was it yet the
owner being ugly money faint nothing and
you know what he was making millions for
that look at who thanked Chris so it was
like he was robbing his old people
that's what really pissed me off well
you don't want to go rob [ __ ]
somebody white go rob a [ __ ] black
dude but you're robbing the same [ __ ]
people that you know these are your
people they have nothing they look what
he grew up he grew up in a [ __ ]
project I mean there was an earthquake
they have sleeping [ __ ] tents outside
are you [ __ ] kidding me and you can't
give us an extra $50 so that's why to
this day I don't like that [ __ ]
at all
because he he [ __ ] his own people or
[ __ ] somebody else I don't I mean I
don't want you to [ __ ] somebody else but
go [ __ ] somebody else because this isn't
about a real estate deal this had
nothing to do with a drug deal this had
no knew it none of these type of deals
you know what this had to do with me
talent talent and when it comes to
talent man I know what it feels like to
be [ __ ] rejected and to be [ __ ]
looked at and spit in your [ __ ] face
it's not a good feeling it's not a good
[ __ ] feel especially when you don't
have much especially when you don't have
much going for you and yeah that's part
of the [ __ ] game Joey you shouldn't
want I understand it's part of the game
but it's not what he did it's how they
did it it's how they did it immediately
not repeatedly but like I just told you
it's like you know it's likely if I'm
Jewish and me and you were friends and
I'm booking some and I keep [ __ ] you
over and over again I don't know that I
care about after what I see I always
going I'm your I'm saying i always say
Shalom then make-believe I'm such a big
Jew you're following me I heard great
things about you
yeah it's all [ __ ] well anyway I
don't know how I'm gonna hold you in
traffic this poor bastard God knows what
he needs he needs to [ __ ] he's the
star of death he needs another star
that to get them going my man Rodrigo
boys anyway I love you brother thank you
mother tonight Oh fool and we'll check
in with your souls to see what the
[ __ ] going on don't forget my man
Felipe Esparza we'll be in New York City
this Saturday night at the PlayStation
Vita
yes Manhattan what time 8:00 o'clock
we'll do
hosted by Luis Guzman like I said in the
beginning the NFL playoffs are finally
here and I want to tell you guys about
my book EEG again the number one rated
online sports book all right
they have odds on everything live
betting an all-new prop builder create
your own betting slips bet how you want
you can bet your friends LeBron will
score 30 plus and have 10 plus assists
why not better that my bookie and put
your money where your mouth is
bet from your desktop tablet or whether
there's a world class mobile site that
lets you bet anytime anywhere okay you
can bet from your desktop tablet on
their world-class mobile site that lets
you bet from anytime anywhere my bookie
offers the fastest no hassle payouts
when you win and that's the most
important thing just putting the better
than Z Z getting paid that's what they
specialize in my bookie dodgy so join
now today at my bookie dot AG and
they'll match your deposit went up to a
50% bonus you understand me the NFL
playoffs are here basketballs here this
is your time to make some money go to my
bookie dot AG today and bet on the
Internet's favorite sports back where
you play you win and you get paid number
two like I told in the beginning blue
apron is deleting milk a delivery
service in the US their mission is to
make incredible home cook accessible to
everyone they achieved this by
supporting a more sustainable food
system setting the highest standards for
ingredients and building a community of
home chefs blue apron offers three plans
they got the two-person meal plan the
family plan and the [ __ ] wine plan
have you heard about this one
but anyway what they gonna start doing
ending on February 26 is blue apron is
teaming up with hole 30 to bring you
delicious recipe
our menu will feature to hold 30
approved recipes each week like Mexican
spice barramundi with avocado or
togarashi chicken lettuce cups with
avocado and kale and sweet potato salad
kick-starting and whole third ok the
thing about this is listen it's flexible
blue apron offers 12 new recipes each
week and customers can pick two three or
four recipes fit you know based on what
best fits their schedule let me tell you
what this week's menu is just so you
know right we got the Steak Diane with
mushroom pan sauce and mashed potatoes
tremendous we got Lee's favorite general
tiles chicken with bok choy and jasmine
rice we got whole 30 approved Mexican
spice barramundi and we got whole 30
approved togarashi chicken lettuce cups
with avocado not only that on do you eat
healthy you learn how to cook and it's a
family type thing because the best part
of the day happened over dinner so we
want you to share that perspective so
right now blue apron is treating the
church family listeners to their first
three meals that's three meals on the
arm three meals on the house if you
visit blue apron Tom slash Joey like I
said go to this week's menu and we'll
give you 30% off with free shrimping at
blue apron calm slash Joey like I said
in the beginning and I'll say it again
blue apron is a better way to cook and
listen if you cook you gotta eat and
when you eat your [ __ ] and when your
[ __ ] you got a dirty [ __ ] and here at
the church so what's happening now we
don't want this that's why we go with
hello to ChiCom listen the number one
portable [ __ ] bidet out there okay
takes you ten minutes to install and
guess what your [ __ ] is tip-top
[ __ ] Magoo after that a nun
weed out of your [ __ ] that's how
clean it is sparkless nice you could
smell that [ __ ] it doesn't
smell like fireworks you understand me
that's when you know your [ __ ] is
clean number two they come in different
colors and number three they come with a
60 90 day guarantee I forget right now
but it don't matter because me and Lee a
[ __ ] guerrillas and Arbor Day is
still cleaning our [ __ ] spiny shiny
spotty [ __ ] new every [ __ ] day so
this thing will last forever because
we've been busted with what lead so all
that hummus caked around his [ __ ] and
all that [ __ ] eats if it [ __ ] works
on this [ __ ]
imagine what it'll do for you go - hello
- she calm right now I'll press in
Church Bab and get 10% off your birthday
whatever one you want whatever color and
they start at $69 go - hello - she calm
today I want to thank hello - she I want
to thank my bookie Dodd AG I want to
thank my men over there blue apron and I
want to thank Felipe Rodrigo for coming
down today
don't forget Austin Texas next Thursday
night and the Thursday after that
Charlotte the [ __ ] comedy zone so
[ __ ] shine your shoes and wash your
[ __ ] uncle Joey's coming to town have a
great weekend we'll see you
[ __ ] Monday morning Lee take
that [ __ ] meal